what would a filmmaker need to know
about shooting an interview in terms of
like setting up their camera let's say
they're using a DSLR like the one we're
using now what are some of the tips that
they should be aware of well you number
one you'll know with a DSLR no you're
going to have a beautiful picture
because of the large sensor but
essentially it's still a still camera
not a video camera especially when it
comes to audio audio is your biggest
workaround now you have your dual dual
system which is like an old
16-millimeter film film camera with
inaugural you know tape recorder so you
have to sync up the sound in the picture
because you can't really when you use an
hdslr you're not going to bring the
audio straight into the camera generally
speaking unless you really you know
that's you're going to get over
modulated in audio and you're going to
get all kinds of problems you're going
to want to do it separately so that's a
workaround there the ergonomics on a
DSLR are not the same as a shoulder
mount a camera that is which is why you
see all these incredible rigs they come
up with what you're generally speaking
almost more expensive than the cameras
you know by various vendors where you
can have shoulder mounts and it's all
about stabilizing it because these most
of these image stabilization lenses are
still still camera lenses they're not
the same as a video image stabilized
video lens so you know I used to think I
was a very good handheld camera person
and I'm you know for a director I do
some of my own shooting but just
generally b-roll and stuff I hire you
know really good dps and operators but
this first time I operated my canon DSLR
was at a rally the downtown rally
immigration rally and I did a lot of
stuff in the crowd and I brought it back
and it was horrible it was so jittery as
I guy I couldn't believe i shot it but
the point was it's not image stabilized
the same way as a video cameras so you
know get this thing rock solid be
prepared for the sound work around but
you know you're going to have
spectacular images they're really
amazing what you can get out of the hg
slrs now
you